I'm afraid I can't say very much at all
I've been asked not to say anything at
all however what I need to do first and
foremostly
is to say thank you so much to my wife
my family and my close family and
friends for their trust and their
support to me I think they've been
amazingly courageous I think they've
been very dignified in all that they
have done and I'm thankful secondly to
my legal team headed up by Simon Mackay
that has been absolutely fantastic and
he has supported me and my family
far more than can be necessary I'd say
they've been superb and thirdly to the
great British public and the world
audience far further afield there have
been absolutely wonderful in their
support and I'd like to say thank you
very much it has been extremely humbling
very very humbling getting everything
that has come in I'm afraid that's all I
can say at the moment but for the media
support that's been out there as well
thank you people just thank you to the
world for being so kind
I cannot take any more I'm sorry very
very happy last three weeks and we got
justice today
and I think everybody in that port fight
the public thank you everybody
sorry are you gonna do conviction we're
out in the field doing things to know
that the British public
the public have shown their support and
definitely their support for the British
forces
so it can only help people out there
fighting for our country to see that
justice has been done today did you ever
dream of this one noon did you ever
think that it might not I didn't dare to
dream that this would be the outcome but
it's great oh yes